hello this is Matthew with simply learn
and today we're gonna go through and
introduce you to DevOps when it go
through a number of key elements today
the first two will be reviewing models
that you're already probably using for
delivering solutions into your company
and the most popular one is waterfall
followed by agile then we'll look at
DevOps and how DevOps differs from the
two models and how it also borrows and
leverages the best of those models we'll
go through each of the phases that are
used in typical DevOps delivery and then
the tools use within those phases to
really improve the efficiencies within
DevOps finally we'll summarize the
advantages that DevOps brings to you and
your teams so let's go through waterfall
so wonderful is a traditional delivery
model that's being used for many decades
for delivering solutions not just IT
solutions and digital solutions but
either way before that it has its
history it goes back to World War 2 so
waterfall is a model that is used to
capture requirements and they cascade
each key deliverable through a series of
different stage gates that is used for
building out the solution so let's take
you through each of those stage gates
the first that you may have done is
requirements analysis and this is where
you sit down with the actual client and
you understand specifically what they
actually do and what they're looking for
in the software that you're going to
build and then from that requirement
analysis you'll build out a project
planning so you have an understanding of
what the level of work is needed to be
able to be successful in delivering the
solution after that you've got your plan
then you start doing the development and
that means that the programmers start
coding out their solution that build out
their applications to build out the
websites and this can take weeks or even
months to actually do all the work when
you've done your coding and development
then you send it to another group that
does testing and they'll do full
regression testing of your application
against the systems and databases that
integrate with your application you
test it against of the actual code
you'll do manual testing you do UI
testing and then after you've delivered
the solution you go into maintenance
mode which is just kind of making sure
that the application keeps working
there's any security risks that you
address those security risks but the
problem you have though is that there
are some challenges however that you
have with the waterfall model the
cascading deliveries and those complete
and separated stage gates means that
it's very difficult for any new
requirements from the client to be
integrated into the project so if a
client comes back and it's the project
has been running for six months and
they've gone hey we need to change
something that means that we have to
almost restart the whole project it's
very expensive and it's very
time-consuming also if you spend weeks
and months away from your clients and
you deliver a solution that they are
only just going to see after you spend a
lot of time working on it they could be
pointing out things that are in the
actual final application that they don't
want or not implemented correctly or
lead to just general unhappiness the
chance you then have is if you want to
add back in the clients feedback to
restart the whole waterfall cycle again
so the client will come back to you with
a list of changes and then you go back
and you have to start your programming
you have to then start your testing
process again and just you're really
adding in lots of additional time into
the project so using the waterfall model
companies have soon come to realize that
you know the clients just aren't able to
get their feedback and quickly
effectively it's very expensive to make
changes once the team's have started
working and the requirement in today's
digital world is that solutions simply
must be delivered faster and this has
led for a specific change in agile and
we start implementing the agile model so
the agile model allows programmers to
create prototypes and get those
prototypes to the client with the
requirements faster and the client is
able to then send the requirements back
to the programmer with feedback this
allows us to create what we call a
feedback loop we're able to get
information
to the client and the client can get
back to the development team much faster
typically when we were actually going
through this process we're looking at
the engagement cycle being about two
weeks and so it's much faster than the
traditional waterfall approach and so we
can look at each feedback loop as
comprising of four key elements we have
the planning where we actually sit down
with the client understand what they're
looking for we then have coding and
testing that is building out the code
and the solution that is needed for the
client and then we review with the
clients the changes that have happened
but we do all this in a much tighter
cycle that we call a sprint and then
typically a sprint will last for about
two weeks
some companies run sprints every week
some run every four weeks it's up to you
as a team to decide how long you want to
actually run a sprint but typically it's
two weeks and so every two weeks the
client is able to provide feedback into
that loop and so you were able to move
quickly through iterations and so if we
get to the end of sprint two and the
client says hey you know what we need to
make a change you can make those changes
quickly and effectively for Sprint three
what we have here is a breakdown of the
ceremonies and the approach that you
bring to agile so typically what will
happen is that a product leader will
build out a backlog of products and what
we call a product backlog and this will
be just a whole bunch of different
features and it may be small features or
bug fixes all the way up to large
features that may actually span over
multiple sprints but when you go through
the sprint planning you want to actually
break out the work that you're doing so
the team has a mixture of small medium
and large solutions that they can
actually implement successfully into
this four into plan and then once you
actually start running your sprint again
it's a two-week activity you meet every
single day the two with the agile sprint
team to ensure that everybody is staying
on track and if there's any blockers
that those blockers are being addressed
effectively and immediately the goal at
the end of the two weeks is to have a
deliverable product that you can put in
front of the customer and the customer
can then do a
view the key advantages you have of
running a sprint with agile is that the
client requirements are better
understood because the client is really
integrated into the scrum team they're
there all the time and the product is
delivered much faster than with a
traditional waterfall model you're
delivering features at the end of each
sprint versus waiting weeks months or in
some cases years for a waterfall project
to be completed however there are also
some distinct disadvantages the product
itself really doesn't get tested in a
production round it's only being tested
on the developer computers and it's
really hard when you're actually running
agile for the Sprint team to actually
build out a solution easily and
effectively on their computers to mimic
the production environment and the
developers and the operations team are
running in separate silos so you have
your development team running their
sprint and actually working to build out
the features but then when they're done
at the end of their sprint and they want
to do a release they kind of fling it
over the wall at the operations team and
then it's the operations team job to
actually install the software and make
sure that the environment is running in
a stable fashion that is really
difficult to do when you have the two
teams really not working together
so here we have is a breakdown of that
process with the developers submitting
their work to the operations team for
deployment and then the operations team
may submit their work to the production
servers but what if there is an error
what if there was a setup configuration
error with the developers test
environment that doesn't match the
production environment there may be a
dependency that isn't there there may be
a link to an API that doesn't exist in
production and so you have these
challenges that the operations team are
constantly faced with and their
challenge is that they don't know how
the code works
so this is where DevOps really comes in
and let's dig into how DevOps which is
developers and operators working
together is the key for successful
continuous delivery so DevOps is
as an evolution of the agile model the
agile model really is great for
gathering requirements and for
developing and testing out your
solutions and what we want to be able to
do is kind of address that challenge and
that gap between the ops team and the
dev team and so with DevOps what we're
doing is bringing together the
operations team and the development team
into a single team and they are able to
then work more seamlessly together
because they are integrated to be able
to build out solutions that are being
tested in a production like environment
so that when we actually deploy we know
that the code itself will work the
operations team is then able to focus on
what they're really good at which is
analyzing the production environment and
being able to provide feedback to the
developers on what is being successful
so we're able to make adjustments in our
code that it's based on data so let's
step through the different phases of a
DevOps team so typically you'll see that
the DevOps team will actually have eight
phases now this is somewhat similar to
agile and what I'd like to point out at
time is that again agile and DevOps are
very closely related but agile devops
are closely related delivery models that
you can use with DevOps it's really just
extending that model with the key phases
that we have here so let's step through
each of these key phases so the first
phase is planning and this is where we
actually sit down with a business team
and we go through and understand what
their goals are the second stage is as
you can imagine and this is where it's
all very similar to agile is that the
code is actually start coding but they
typically they'll start using tools such
as git which is a distributed version
control software it makes it easier for
developers to all be working on the same
code base rather than bits of the code
that is rather than them working on bits
of the code that they are responsible
for so the goal with using tools such as
git is that each developer always has
the current and latest version of the
code you then use tools such as mavin
and Gradle as a way to consistently
build out your environment and then we
also use tools to actually autumn
our testing now what's interesting is
when we use tools like selenium and
j-unit is that we're moving into a world
where our testing is scripted the same
as our build environment and the same as
using our get around we can start
scripting out these environments and so
we actually have scripted production
environments that we're moving towards
Jenkins is the integration phase that we
use for our tools and another point here
is that the tools that we're listing
here these are all open source tools
these are tools that any team can start
using we want to have tools that control
and manage the deployment of code into
the production environments and then
finally tools such as ansible and chef
will actually operate and manage those
production environments so that when
code comes to them that that code is
compliant with the production
environment so that when the code is
then deployed to the many different
production servers that the expected
results of those servers which is you
want them to continue running is
received and then finally you monitor
the entire environment so you can just
zero in on spikes and issues that are
relevant to either the code or changing
consumer habits on the site so let's
step through some of those tools that we
have in the DevOps environments so here
we have is a breakdown of the DevOps
tools that we have and again one of the
things I want to point out is that these
tools are open source tools there are
also many other tools this is just
really a selection of some of the more
popular tools that are being used but
it's quite likely that you're already
using some of these tools today you may
already be using Jenkins you may already
be using git but some of the other tools
really help you create a fully
scriptable environment so that you can
actually start scripting out your entire
DevOps
toolset this really helps when it comes
to speeding up your delivery because the
more you can actually script out of the
work that you're doing the more
effective you can be at running
automation against those scripts and the
more effective you can be at having a
consistent experience so let's step
through this DevOps Pross
so we go through and we have our
continuous delivery which is our plan
code build and test environment so what
happens if you want to make it release
well the first thing you want to do is
send out your files to the building ramp
and you want to be able to test the code
that you've been created because we're
scripting everything in our code from
the actual unit testing being done to
the all the way through to the
production environment because we're
testing or that we can very quickly
identify whether or not there are any
defects within the code if there are
defects we can send that code right back
to the developer with a message saying
what the defect is and the developer can
then fix that with information that is
real on the either the code or the
production environment if however your
code passes the the scripting tests they
can then be deployed and once is out to
deployment you can then start monitoring
that environment what this provides you
is the opportunity to speed up your
delivery so you go from the waterfall
model which is weeks months or even
years between releases to agile which is
two weeks or four weeks depending on
your sprint cadence to where you are
today with DevOps where you can actually
be doing multiple releases every single
day so there are some significant
advantages and there are companies out
there that are really zeroing in on
those advantages if we take any one of
these companies such as Google Google
any given date will actually process
5,200 new releases on their website
through their DevOps teams in fact they
have some great videos on YouTube that
you can find out on how their develop
teams work Netflix is also a similar
environment now what's interesting with
Netflix is that Netflix have really
fully embraced DevOps within their
development team and so they have a
DevOps team and Netflix is a completely
digital company so they have software on
phones on smart TVs on computers and on
websites
interestingly though the DevOps team for
Netflix is only 70 people and when you
consider that a third of all Internet
traffic on any given date is from
Netflix it's really a reflection on how
effective DevOps can be when you can
actually manage that entire business
with just 70 people so there are some
key advantages that DevOps has it's the
actual time to create and deliver
software is dramatically reduced
particularly compared to waterfall
complexity of maintenance is also
reduced because you're automating and
scripting out your entire environment
you're improving the communication
between all your teams so teams don't
feel like they're in separate silos that
are actually working cohesively together
and that there is continuous integration
and continuous delivery so that your
consumer your customer is constantly
being delighted so we have six key
takeaways that hopefully that you learn
from this presentation we went through
two delivery models the waterfall and
agile model and waterfall is that a
legacy model that is still very popular
but it has some restrictions in that the
actual delivery can take weeks or months
for the actual project agile is a
modification of the waterfall model
where we're actually reducing the actual
activities down to a two or four-week
cadence and DevOps looks at what the
benefits are with agile but then
integrates the actual operations team
with the development team so that we're
actually having this tight communication
between the dev team and ops team so we
have this DevOps operations there are
key phases that we have typically with
DevOps and some of those are reflected
within agile and the others have been
optimized such as being able to script
out your environments and effectively
for quick continuous delivery and then
we have key tools that are open source
tools that you can start using today and
then finally the whole opportunity with
DevOps is designed around speeding up
your delivery and continuously
delighting your customers so hopefully
this was of benefit to you today if it
was please like and subscribe
below leave any comments and we'll get
back to you thanks very much
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here